hey youtubers is Charlie you guys may
have heard about the huge info dump that
Marvel did about all their phase 3
movies I'm going to start with Spider
Man infinity war and Captain Marvel I
know it seems like all the studios are
dropping all their comic-book news right
now I think it's mostly a coincidence
that Marvel invited a bunch of
journalists to see everything that's
happening in phase 3 very little of
phase 4 but I will address that so what
I did is I broke like a couple of the
really big movies into a couple separate
videos so this will mostly be Spider Man
Captain Marvel stuff leading into
infinity war in right after that because
some of the movies overlap but if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get everything I do Marvel videos
every week so what I'm going to do is
I'll explain the timeline real quick
here because Captain Marvel and
spider-man are tail end of Marvel phase
3 there's still like a whole bunch of
films there's Black Panther footage to
talk about I'll do that in my next video
they even confirm thor ragnarok warbound
from Planet Hulk so all that stuff's
coming but starting with Spider Man
Captain Marvel they showed off Captain
Marvel's costume they didn't have any
footage they had concept art of that and
they're getting ready to announce the
director so I'll explain the suit in a
second the bigger stuff the more
immediate stuff is spider-man
everybody's freaking out about what his
future in the MCU is going to be do not
worry if there's anybody that's good at
calming fans down it's Kevin Feige what
he did is assure us that spider-man
would participate in a big way in the
fourth Avengers film which is happening
right after Captain Marvel so the
Captain Marvel movie is coming out March
8th 2019 that fourth Avengers film is
coming out May 3rd right after that and
then the sequel to spider-man homecoming
which they're just calling spider-man
homecoming 2 is coming out July of that
same year so now you understand why I'm
talking about these two characters in
the same video because you have Captain
Marvel then two movies featuring
spider-man happening right after that so
on the spider-man side of things they
haven't even gotten to the first movie
yet so there wasn't a lot to talk about
for what's happening with the future of
spider-man but you know the symbiote
saga is a big thing in the spider-man
history but think about the early
Avengers hopeful spider-man in the idea
of the iron spider symbiote like he gets
the suit messes up big-time Tony takes
it back because he's not ready for it
and then
he finds a way to earn it back through
his own acts of heroism wearing his old
homemade version of the costume and the
important thing that they haven't
addressed yet but is actually a pretty
big deal is whether or not Peter is
going to be a junior in high school
during that second spider-man homecoming
movie or if they'll move in real time
and he'll be a senior because in the
real world it'll be two years after we
see this first spider-man homecoming
movie he's about 16 years old he's a
sophomore in high school so logically in
two years he would be a senior so is he
going to skip a year will he be a senior
are they going to do a third spider-man
homecoming movie those are all questions
that'll have to wait till after they
renew their sharing arrangement and I
know that was the thing that everybody
was freaking out about a while ago
because of Amy Pascal's comment I'll
link that video at the end of this but
my belief is reading between the lines
is that she said that even though it may
never happen again that just means that
it won't happen again until they renew
their arrangement but even if they do a
third spider-man homecoming movie and
Peter Parker is out of high school he'll
still be a very young version of the
character but I think the whole idea is
is that by that first Avengers movie he
will be an Avenger
if you survive fan OHS with the Infinity
Gauntlet you have essentially earned
your spot on the Avengers and even
though I'm putting them together in this
video Captain Marvel and spider-man I
don't think that he's going to appear
anywhere in her movie they did have a
brief romance in the comics like they
went out for a little while but I think
fans like either went crazy about it or
they absolutely hated it and this is all
around the Siege era so this is way
before what's happening right now the
current Captain Marvel title like if
you're new to the Captain Marvel
character you've never read her before I
would recommend that you start with the
new stuff the mighty Captain Marvel in
the way the first couple of issues read
it's almost like they're writing it for
people who are like oh my god I'm
excited about brie Larson and Captain
Marvel but I have no idea what's going
on with the character there's all this
history so that would be the place to
start but way back when she was still
miss Marvel so this is like way back
2008-2009 I think it's like Miss Marvel
number 34 she's on the run from the
government she doesn't have her powers
so he saves her and as they're sitting
around sort of collecting themselves he
kind of asks her out on a date and then
they pay that off with the date in Miss
Marple number 47 many issues later so
then later they pair the characters
together during her first appearance as
the Captain Marvel character as she been
Miss Marvel for forever in the comics
she became a captain and then Captain
America gave her the idea to start using
the Captain Marvel name after Captain
Marvel as a way to honor him as well as
acknowledge her rank technically she's a
colonel now but a lot has happened
between the time she debuted with the
Captain Marvel name in the new version
of the costume that happened in a
spider-man comic so this is still well
before Marvel sort of reimagined when
all-new all-different before Secret Wars
but an avenging spider-man number one
she gives them a ride so you see this
funny panel here where he's riding on
her back so obviously this is a much
older version of Peter Parker you might
see a version of this scene in infinity
war but Peter Parker's in high school so
the closest thing you're going to see to
a romance between the two of them is
hinges having a super big crush on her
which all the other Avengers will
spider-man is going to have to get in
line behind Iron Man you can just
picture the way the Tony Stark is going
to react to a fully powered Captain
Marvel
remember Iron Man 3 when Pepper Potts
Hulk's out on extremists and kills
Aldrich Killian in iron man's jaw just
hits the floor like he's kind of scared
kind of excited at the same time that's
probably how he's going to react to
Captain Marvel when she's at full
strength so we can talk more about
Spider Man Captain Marvel crossover when
we get closer to those movies coming out
let's just say that all the characters
have had really funny run-ins in the
comics before it'll be funny to see they
lay any Easter eggs for that when they
get to infinity war and all the
characters meet on screen but the
Captain Marvel concept arts that they
showed up there were about three
pictures too with her suit on in one
with her using her powers just kind of
show you the scope of her abilities like
I said if you haven't read Captain
Marvel before start with Mighty Captain
Marvel because the costume that they
showed off in the concept art looks a
lot like that version now it's a little
bit different the colors aren't quite as
bright it looks a little bit like this
this is just fan art but it's very close
and I know everybody was wondering about
the sash there are a couple reasons for
Captain Marvel sash one it's a way to
honor her costume when she was Miss
Marvel so it's a way to carry that
forward like say all this history has
come before but it also serves this
visual function on the page when they're
flying
on screen and there's nothing else
around it gives you a sense of motion
which direction she's headed so it's a
drink of comic book artist to make her
pop on the page more and it's the same
trick they used for the Iron Fist
character when they created him back in
the 70s that's the reason that he had a
sash so it serves a practical function
as well as a legacy function what about
her powers though they said they were
changing her origin story just a little
bit so that it didn't read like Green
Lantern they didn't want it to feel like
you know space object comes gives her
powers because she gets into this freak
accident with a cream machine called the
psyche magnetron and she becomes this
battery for energy she has a whole bunch
of power so one the biggest one is
absorbing energy so if you haven't read
The Ultimates it's actually a really
cool comic she has the blue Marvel who's
kind of like an antimatter reactor blast
her with energy so that she can then
absorb it and redirect it so when she
absorbs energy it enhances what she
already had so she's already super
strong she can fly and she has this
cosmic awareness which is sort of like a
cosmic version of spider-man spidey
sense so imagine in the Captain Marvel
movie if Thanos were coming to Earth
during Avengers infinity war she would
get a sense for that like oh my god
something really bad is about to happen
in the way that spider-man could sense
that something really bad around the
corner is getting ready to happen so
because Kevin Feige has been teasing her
power levels are going to be so much
greater than the characters that we've
seen so far at least from earthnow Thor
is like one of the most powerful
characters in the Marvel Universe but
he's not from Earth it's just that it's
important that she be the connective
tissue between the cosmic movies in the
earth-based movies Kevin Feige said that
was a big thing and that sort of plays
into her role in the comics too she's
the leader of Alpha Flight which is sort
of like this satellite agency that
exists in orbit and protects the Earth
from extraterrestrial threats so that's
kind of going to be what her future in
the MCU is so when she's not hanging
around with the other Avengers in their
movies she's going to be in outer space
in Earth's orbit just protecting from
anybody that comes looking for trouble
so it makes sense if she's going to be
this earth-based character who handles
extraterrestrial threats that when they
get to her movie there's going to be a
cosmic villain that comes to earth in
because her origin story is so tied up
in
Kri mythology there should be an element
of that but they haven't said anything
about who the villain of the movie is
going to be they really only showed her
in the concept art fighting this giant
robot just to show off her powers
they're really only a couple of giant
big green robots in the Marvel Universe
but it might be a version of Arsenal
alpha which is a Miss Marvel villain
from the comics but it's like this robot
that was created by Howard Stark that
later gets turned into a villain so it's
all just speculation we don't know
exactly who the bill under the Captain
Marvel movie is going to be so you guys
can let me know what you want them to do
from the comics so we'll see how it goes
down but there's going to be a whole
bunch of new spider-man stuff dropping
really soon that movies coming in June
so the press tour is getting ready to
start if you've been seeing all the
guardians footage this dropping that
they're going to be doing that for
spider-man really soon but what's going
to happen next is is unless there's new
footage dropping from other people I'm
going to be doing some thor ragnarok
black panther I'll be talking about
warbound in the footage they showed off
for black panther it was all really cool
so why do you wait for that to post you
can click here to watch the trailer for
the DC EU superman prequel series that
they might be doing they haven't
confirmed it yet but it's a pretty cool
trailer and you can click here for my
guardians of the galaxy video thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you